[Music]
corporate giants like Amazon United
Health and CVS are investing billions
into Primary Care practices with deals
tapping into the nation's four trillion
dollar Healthcare market and it's part
of a shift in America's costly Health
Care System moving away from the
traditional fee for service towards
value-based care that model is about
paying providers for keeping patients
healthy while a fee-for-service model is
when medical providers are paid based on
the amount of services performed
so why are companies spending billions
on Primary Care practices and what could
the growing shift to value-based care
mean for doctors patients and health
insurers the U.S spends more per capita
on health care than any other developed
Nation but still fares worse on most
major health measures Health experts say
the incentives baked into America's fee
for service system are part of the
problem
so critics say that under the
fee-for-service model it basically
encourages providers to recommend as
many services as possible which drives
up the cost of Health Care without
necessarily ensuring patients are at the
Forefront of care and essentially
doctors are rewarded for the volume of
healthcare services they provide now
companies like Amazon CVS and Walgreens
are tapping into the growing value-based
care movement that model provides
incentives to improve patient Health
outcomes within hospitals and doctors
offices in value-based care the idea is
to keep track of the patient to have
more contact between primary care
doctors and patients and reduce the
amount of time that people actually
spend in hospitals where the costs are
very high those costs are high for
patients and health insurers some
Private health plans and government
programs like Medicare have already
adopted this model they want to move
more of the Health Care system to that
approach which makes providers
accountable for some or all of the cost
of their patients care while value-based
care can be traced back decades the 2010
Affordable Care Act accelerated the
government's transition to this model
the government essentially said that
it'll start shifting a lot of health
care towards value-based care with the
idea being to control costs still so
there can be downsides to a value-based
Model A key concern is that patients
might be delayed in seeing Specialists
or in undergoing procedures and
basically insurers and providers could
be doing that to prevent costs from
escalating one obstacle behind shifting
to a value-based model is a shortage in
primary care physicians or pcps because
the U.S Healthcare System rewards more
expensive procedures medical students
may prefer to become cardiologists or
surgeons a cardiologist makes close to
500 000 on average whereas a primary
care physician will make around two
hundred thousand in other countries pcps
compose a much higher proportion of all
practicing Physicians for example 45
percent in France compared to 12 percent
in the United States yet pcps play a
central role in keeping people healthy
and preventing problems before they
begin what happens is many Americans
don't see a primary care physician they
can't find one or they can't get an
appointment for a month many times
people don't know they have something
and they end up in a hospital where they
have to get a much more expensive
procedure to help reduce higher Health
costs Downstream a host of companies are
now spending billions on Primary Care
practices United Health a massive
conglomerate that includes 60 000
Physicians and an insurance business is
one of the furthest along in PCP
Investments through its medical provider
arm Optum care and has been buying up
multi-specialty physician practices to
provide Care at home virtually and on
site the idea is to keep people out of
the hospital because that's where the
costs are highest meanwhile Amazon is
planning to buy a primary care company
one medical a practice that operates
more than 180 medical offices in 25 U.S
markets the 3.9 billion dollar deal
could give Amazon a larger foothold in
offering Health Care Services to
employers
the company CVS health is also stepping
into the mix with a deal to pay 8
billion dollars for signify Health a
company focused on in-home evaluations
ultimately CPS wants to be not only your
pharmacist and your insurer through its
at Norm but it also wants to be your
Village Clinic then there's Walgreens
after buying a controlling stake in
startup Clinic chain Village MD it
struck a roughly nine billion dollar
deal to combine with Summit Health a
large owner of urgent care centers so
how exactly do these companies plan to
make money off of these investments in
practice a value-based reimbursement
model means providing Financial rewards
for better patient outcomes it can also
be tied to a capitation system which
pays Healthcare Providers a fixed amount
for each patient they deliver care to
per unit of time this prioritizes the
patient and cost saving over Services
which can significantly reduce Health
spending still some healthcare
economists worry whether this
value-based approach will benefit
patients or just reduce costs and
improve the bottom line for providers
and insurers for example a primary care
physician might be more reluctant to
allow a patient to go see a specialist
or to perform a more expensive procedure
ultimately some healthcare economists
say moving away from a fee-for-service
model could help temper ballooning
health care costs in the U.S as more and
more of these bigger companies get into
value-based care it's just going to
accelerate the move towards value-based
care and away from this fee-for-service
model
foreign